Oh pets LaDainian Tomlinson the tail he
was hot wasn't happy because after the
Patriots beat the 14 and 2 Chargers in
their own building
Patriots players were doing the shawn
merriman lights-out dance in the middle
of field right and LaDainian Tomlinson
not a big fan of that gesture it was
Troy Brown with the strip of Marlon
McCree it was riche a Caldwell with the
recovery the game was over at that point
if Marlon McCree holders well after that
interception it's done
and the Patriots find a way to win and
what if Marlon decree holds on that ball
I know we're going back 13 years for
this one yeah but Marty Schottenheimer
doesn't get fired that's for damn sure
and Marty Schottenheimer and the
Chargers may have gone to the Super Bowl
and they may have won it that year that
was the year that the Colts beat the
Bears in Miami right and the Colts would
have had to go to San Diego Chargers in
the AFC championship game and maybe
Peyton Manning never wins the Super Bowl
with the Colts Chris maybe Tony Dungy is
not in the Hall of Fame
if Marlin McCree holds on to that ball
because without a Super Bowl win it
makes it hard to put Tony Dungy in well
I know he the ripple effects of this one
are what are amazing I mean you know oh
yeah I mean yes so stay with 2006 you
know of course I was playing at that
point that was the year I lost my spleen
but the Chargers were the best team in
football that year and there's no doubt
about it and they were the better team
on the field that day and didn't even
play their best game yeah they messed it
up and that's what's crazy about you
know quarterbacks in the NFL you know
you look at him go but Phillip Rivers
hasn't won in any big games well yeah
here's a one year where he put his team
in position to win the damn game and
other people failed him but we'll look
back in history and go Philip Rivers
didn't win big games you know and it's
just not fair that's what happens at
quarterback position too much but man I
have a hard time Mike believing the
course that they don't they win that
game that that seals the deal and I have
a hard time believing they don't win the
next week with the Colts coming into
town a team that I think they matched up
with very well at the time and we saw
that in the following year where you
know the Chargers went up to
Indianapolis and beat them in a
divisional playoff game but yeah I would
if the Chargers win that game against
the Patriots I would peg them the Super
Bowl champs
like I said I think they were better
than the Colts I definitely think they
were better than that Chicago bear team
they win the Super Bowl and then what is
the ripple effect from there Mike
because now it's 2007 and yes we know
that's the year the Patriots going to
feeded but also the Colts would be a
different team in 2007 too because they
have not won a Super Bowl so Dungey and
Manning are still hungry and mad and you
know what just chomping and a bit bigger
than ever to wear you know it makes me
think that 2007 might have been
different to with if this were the
outcome or scenario yeah you're right I
mean if the cult's don't win that one
they've got even greater incentive to
keep trying ride in that one it is for
the team that wins it all to go back to
zero and zero and reset and do it all
over again after winning it all it sets
the stage for a team like the Patriots
take over the conference and take over
the league although they obviously
didn't win the Super Bowl but it could
we could have had we could have had the
Manning brothers squaring off in the
Super Bowl I mean right and then seven
right or we could have had the three
quarterbacks from the 2004 draft when
win three Super Bowls in a row with
Roethlisberger and o-5 Philip Rivers and
O six and Manning in those seven that
was another thing I thought about where
I just wanna said whoa that would have
put that quarterback class into another
stratosphere you know they win Super
Bowls and years you know two three and
four of their careers consecutively that
would have been kind of a phenomenal
storyline to go with it but yeah that
this is that those Chargers teams Mike
even leaning back into what was drew
breezes last year they're two thousand
four or five five man they were just
phenomenal I mean they were in the
conversation one of the years I know
they didn't make the playoffs I think
that was a 2004 season or maybe that was
the five season but they were like I
know within the NFL in the conversation
for oh that's one of the best teams in
football and they just never did
anything to kind of put themselves on
the map and I mean think about it that
year after the first year after they let
drew Brees walk away and they make
Philip Rivers the unquestioned starter
they they have that fourteen more
disease oh right and that was Brees
first year with the Saints and actually
the Saints did better that year than the
Chargers right because the Saints made
it to the NFC Championship and that was
the post-katrina year I mean a lot of
crazy storylines in the NFL in the 2006
season and it may have been even crazier
it could have been the Chargers and the
Bears and and and hook hell there's
still a chance we go back and do this
again
it's Brees versus Rivers it's Brees
getting a shot at the charges in Super
Bowl 41 so about what amazed us on that
one we'll be back with more right after
this
[Music]
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports